today as i'm recording and producing and
uploading this this update video for
februari 2016 it's already the seventh
so we're a little bit behind but i think
as i go through what's going on in
February and what took place in January
you'll see how incredibly busy we've
been as usual I want to begin by
highlighting three big things from the
very start so the first of these is that
I have now officially come on board with
the stoicism today project I will be
taking over the editor position of the
blog and there's a lot more to talk
about coming up in the februari portion
although actually officially I'm
beginning in March the second is that in
January the half-hour Hagel project
passed a very important milestone as far
as getting through this massive text
goes and so I'll talk a little bit about
that it has to do with the reason
section we're going to be doing an awful
lot with a half-hour Hagel this this
coming month but i'll talk about that in
the februari section and the third is
we're having our second in this entire
years worth of workshops in practical
philosophy at the hudson business lounge
in downtown milwaukee coming up this
month it's oriented particularly in
terms of Valentine's Day and romantic
relationships but it applies to other
relationships as well so I'd like to put
that on your radar if you're in the area
come on down it's a free workshop but I
would like you to register ahead of time
I include the link here so let's talk
about the month of January we had three
different no four different events two
of which were connected with the half
hour Hagel project so why don't I begin
with those we did our half hour Hagel
Q&A hangouts one for the general public
one just for Patrian backers and then
towards the very end of the month i
think it was actually on the 31st we did
a Hagel party
in to celebrate making it past this this
very important milestone finishing up
with the self-consciousness section of
the work we also had two other events
which I've included the videos for as
links in the video description here one
was our very first workshop in practical
philosophy a new series that we started
here in Milwaukee for free down at the
Hudson business was a place where I do
quite a bit of my work out of that was
on New Year's resolutions and looking at
them from a stoic perspective whether
one wants to remake them or reconsider
them or how to think through resolutions
in general we also kicked off another
big series a monthly series that is
hosted by the Brookfield Public Library
worlds of speculative fiction so that
means sci-fi and fantasy philosophical
themes and we had our first session
which was surprising just how well
attended it was I think we may have to
get a bigger round table to hold that if
more people show up where we talked
about you know the general you know idea
of the series and how philosophy enters
into science fiction and fantasy and
what what the boundaries between science
fiction and fantasy are so we had a
really great kickoff and we've got more
coming up with that as far as video work
that I did over January a half-hour
Hagel we released our six videos for the
month that's the rate at which I'm
committed to releasing them at this
level of support and we made it through
that like I said the self-consciousness
self-consciousness section and began the
new pretty massive it's the second
largest section in the book called
reason we release the first video of
that and I'm continuing to release the
epictetus core concept videos there's
still some of those left in stock you
can well imagine how many I created for
that course that I taught as a free open
access course over
november and december i also uploaded
videos of the events that we had the
workshop and the beginning of the
science fiction/fantasy philosophical
themes series and i also released a you
could call it a teaser video for a
curious course that I publicized and
released during January so that lets the
video work let me now talk about other
stuff so there's this curious course in
philosophy of religion curious is a
platform an educational platform that
allows people to subscribe to it and
then they get the entire world of
courses that are available and it's one
that I particularly like because it lets
me do more than YouTube does I can you
know provide links it you know lets me
break down the videos into sections and
I ask you know mostly true falls or
multiple choice questions that help
people you know think about the material
that they're going over you know i can
add links to handouts or upload handouts
to it so it's a pretty cool platform and
i created this first big course for that
done one smaller course as an experiment
in the past but this first big course
was philosophy of religion so it's 16
lessons a lot of questions handouts
links for pretty cool stuff so that is
is something i've gotten behind quite a
bit the stoicism today project there was
a lot of behind-the-scenes work for that
in in january and there's going to be
even more in February so I'll talk more
about that in the februari portion
started doing some some more tutoring
and philosophical counseling the
tutoring actually doing some
face-to-face tutoring around here in the
Milwaukee area the philosophical
counseling I'm doing remotely as some of
the tutoring is also remotely as well
and I've been building curriculum
or priority thinking this this firm
whose team I've joined in part because I
really like what they're doing they they
take philosophy and find ways to connect
it up with what's going on in
organizations doing consulting doing
management doing coaching doing doing
ethics workshops and and training so you
know it's it's really quite an
opportunity for for me and like I said
I've been working on building curriculum
for them i reworked our reason I owe
websites added a few more descriptive
pages to it about some of the things
that we're doing i tidied up some of our
blogs although not quite so much as i
would have liked i didn't get a lot of
writing down in the month of january
whether academic or more popular but i'm
hoping to to change that that's starting
to become a little bit of a drum beat
these update videos but it's in part
because I've been so busy with with
other matters alright so that is January
now let's talk about this month februari
that we're already one week into so
let's just sort of make believe that i'm
talking about it as if this is on
februari first so i'm not going to try
to you know convince you that an event
that has already taken place hasn't
taken place as a matter of fact i'm
including a link to the video here in
the description but that was a talk that
I gave at the frank Weinberg library in
mequon Wisconsin great audience that
that showed up for it especially at a
night that we were supposed to be
getting hit by a major winter storm that
didn't turn out to be as bad as people
predicted but the talk was on Aristotle
Athens and Alexander the Great and it's
part of this quarterly series that we're
doing that's focused on on placing
philosophers within their historical
context so I'm picking people where the
historical context is particularly
interesting like like Saint Anselm or
Rene Descartes or it for the 20th
century Hana a rent and so that one's
already passed but you know stay tuned
we'll do another one in May now coming
up if you're in this area we're doing
the second of the you know philosophical
themes and speculative fiction and it's
focused this time on JRR Tolkien's world
of middle-earth and what's going on with
that entire project so I'm going to talk
about the Lord of the Rings a bit about
The Hobbit also about the civilian and
about this entire you know cosmos that
that Hulk and created and some of the
key philosophical ideas that you find
working behind the scenes in that so
that's going to happen on the 11th at
the brookfield public library it's a
free talk if you want to come to it by
all means go ahead happen seven o'clock
by the way I should I should say so the
other thing that we've got going on here
in town is the second workshop in the
practical philosophy ideas into action
it's called a series of workshops that
we're giving for free at the Hudson
where we take some some interesting
philosophical concept or distinction and
then apply it to you know pretty common
often day-to-day issues now this one is
an honor of Valentine's Day we're doing
it based on the notion of relationships
particularly romantic relationships and
I'm going to be applying Aristotle's
theory of friendship and you know
showing people how looking at things in
that way might clarify certain issues or
long-standing you no worries that
they've been having and sometimes help
them make better decisions about
relationships going forward so that's
happening on the 17th at the Hudson
business lounge again seven o'clock free
workshops so if you're in the area and
you're interested in in participating in
that come on down on the twenty-fourth
I'm doing a half hour Hagel public q a
google hangout beginning at five o'clock
central standard time that's the time
that I'm on here and so if you've got
any quite
about Hagel in general if you've been
following the half hour Hagel videos you
don't have to be a patreon subscriber to
go to that hang out that one is for the
the entire general public although I do
get quite a few of the spate rien
supporters who do show up for that if
you have questions bring them in and
just you know say dr. Sadler I've got a
Hagel related question and I'll see how
I can tackle it if I can we've got a lot
of events happening in March and so I'm
already starting to prepare for what's
going on in March we've got you know the
fantasy science fiction thing we've got
the the ideas in action workshop we're
doing something for women's hit Women's
History Month on Mary Wollstonecraft but
i'll tell you more about that when we
get to the march video I'm actually
flying to Virginia Commonwealth
University where i'll be doing a talk
therefore the philosophy students and
we've got some other event it's escaping
me right now but anyway there's a lot
going on in march that i have to have to
prepare for videos coming up that you
can wait you know you can anticipate
seeing in in February six half-hour
Hagel videos I'll be producing over the
course of this month all of which are
going to be in this section reason which
we're now moving into full force we just
barely got into it in January and now
we're moving into it we're only going to
get a little of the ways of course into
this massive section which is over 200
paragraphs so I think we'll probably be
in that section well into summer of this
year but we're laying the groundwork for
that I've got quite a few of those
epictetus core concept videos still to
bring out you know some people might be
getting a little sick of Epictetus at
this point but you know it's good stuff
so I think a lot of people can can get
into that and all of course you have
event videos for the talks that i'm
giving i've already posted one of them
for the aristotle athens and alexander
the great i'll be posting the one on
speculative fiction that is Tolkien and
the one from the workshop you know
shortly after I've got them uploaded and
and you know takes a little while
sometimes to turn them around when
you're as busy as I am so what else is
on the horizon like I mentioned before I
have been invited to join the stoicism
today project and I will be taking over
the editing position for the the blog
stoicism today I'm very honored it's
it's it sounds like a lot of work but
there's actually quite a few other
people contributing to it so I'm very
happy about the level of support that
I'll be I'll be getting at least in
terms of you know getting other sets of
eyes on things some of the the you know
scheduling issues all these things that
go into it so that that's something I'm
really looking forward to i'll be doing
some writing from time to time for the
stoicism today blog and you can
anticipate an entry about the the
transition patrick usher is is the
current editor and he's he's leaving
after having essentially built the blog
up and done you know really great work
with it for for a long time so I'm
really happy to be stepping into some
some well prepared shoes the half hour
Hagel project I'm going to be doing
quite a bit of you know what we could
talk about is as awareness work I'm
going to be sending out emails to
colleagues and saying this is a valuable
resource for your students or if you
ever want it to you know get a little
bit more into Hagel here's here's a
valuable resource I'm going to be
talking to people who do digital
humanities and online learning and
saying look here's here's a pretty cool
project for you know at this point sort
of one of a kind do you want to you want
to back it up a little bit do you want
to publicize it do you want to tell
other people about it so you know if
you're in
dress that in the half-hour Hagel
project you know share it with other
people there's the Patrian page which I
include a link to there's the blog which
I also include a link to I'm going to
keep on working on those those videos
and let's see I'm doing a lot of work
with priority thinking this month a lot
of it focused specifically on anger you
know one of my areas of research and how
it fits into the you know the
organizational and leadership setting
there's a lot to be said about that as a
matter of fact enough that I'm a down
the line write a book specifically on
that I'm doing a lot of building
contacts here in the Milwaukee area I
just went to a great talk over at
Marquette University which was about
Aquinas and alexandrov Aphrodisias and
got to meet some some some of the
faculty from there and we're going to be
doing quite a lot of that sort of stuff
around here not just in terms of
academics but also business
organizations and you know other other
places that would might you know be
interested in connecting up with with us
you know ranging from radio stations to
churches to to other types of
organizations I'm still doing or at
least I'm anticipating doing a lot of
tutoring this month particularly since
it's midterm month for for some people
got some philosophical counseling
clients I've been very happy with how
that's been going even though we haven't
done any advertising as of this point if
you're interested in those sorts of
services you can look at the reason I
owe website that discusses them in great
detail one of the things I really want
to do this month is get more writing
done and even though it's a short month
I'm hoping that that will be something
that I get to in part because in a way
i'm sort of like-- on sabbatical and so
there's a little bit of other news that
i should probably talk about the biggest
thing is
that I have resigned from the global
Center for Advanced Studies both in my
role as a professor and as the director
of the Institute of humanities and
Social Sciences so that frees up a bit
of time I'm not teaching any online
courses for marist or a player know this
spring semester so effectively from a
teaching perspective at least up until a
certain point it's sort of like being on
sabbatical although you know as you can
tell I keep pretty busy here I'm not
just you know getting up and looking out
the window and thinking about what I
might write today the last thing that I
do want to talk about sort of
piggybacking on that is that we are
looking at providing courses through
reason I oh not for for credit the
courses that would be for personal
enrichment that people would would take
you know because they want to know
something more about say Plato or
Aristotle or Jacques Lacan it's going to
offer us a great you might say
flexibility and if there is sufficient
interest in taking courses with me it
should be you know something that i can
continue to do quite often so we're
shooting our goal right now is to have a
course ready to offer by April first
it's going to take a lot of work I'm not
even quite sure which course I want to
teach and design and build because you
know those of you have taken courses
with me you know that when you take a
course with me you get a lot of material
I put you know I shoot videos
specifically for the course I produce
handouts I produce entire lesson pages
very you know very interactive so I
haven't quite figured out exactly what
course I interested in doing that amount
of work for yet but I just wanted to put
it out there and put it on people's
radar that that i'll be doing something
along those lines
and yeah a lot of very exciting stuff
happening this month a lot of exciting
stuff on the horizon I hope all of you
have a good remaining three weeks of the
month of February and you'll see me next
time in March probably doing this a
little bit earlier